rewrite the following expression as the
product of positive exponents and then
evaluate the expression when x is equal
to 2. so it gives us x to the negative 3
times 5 to the negative 2 times x
squared so the main thing to realize
here is if i have something to a
negative exponent to a negative exponent
this is the exact same thing as 1 over
that same base to the positive version
of the exponent so x to the negative a
is equal to 1 over x to the a so using
this knowledge just let's apply it right
over here so x to the negative 3
power we can rewrite as 1 over x to the
third power
and then 5 to the negative 2
we can rewrite as 1 over 5 squared and
then finally we have times
times x squared and so we can multiply
this out in the numerator we have 1
times 1 times x squared which is just
equal to x squared in the denominator we
have x to the third times 5 squared
5 squared is 25 and here you could say
implicitly there is a 1 this is the same
thing as x squared over 1. so the
denominator we have 25 times x to the
third so this is going to be 25
times x to the third
and then we can simplify this even more
because both the numerator and the
denominator is divisible by x squared x
squared divided by x squared is one x to
the third divided by x squared is just
going to be equal to x and you could use
other exponent properties you could say
x squared over x to the third is the
same thing as x to the 2 minus 3 power
which is x to the negative 1 power but x
to the negative 1 power we know is the
same thing as 1 over x 1 over x anyway
you do it as long as you do it in a
reasonable way you should get the same
result so when we simplify it we get 1
over
25
25
x
now they want us to evaluate it when x
is equal to 2. so if x is equal to 2 we
get 1 over 25 times 2 which is equal to
1 over 50. and we are done we we rewrote
the expression as a product of positive
exponents that's right over here we made
all the exponents positive and then we
evaluated and we got 1 over 50.